if we have a rectangle with base length
b and height length h we know how to
figure out its area its area
is just going to be the base
is going to be the base
times the height
the base times the height this is just a
review of the area of a rectangle you
just multiply the base times the height
now let's look at a parallelogram and in
this parallelogram our base still has
length b and we still have a height h
so when we talk about the height we're
not talking about the length of these
sides that at least the way i've drawn
them move diagonally we're talking about
if you go from that's from from this
side up here and you were to go straight
down if you were to go at a 90 degree
angle if you were to go perpendicularly
straight down you get to this side
that's going to be that's going to be
our height so in a situation like this
when you have a parallelogram you know
its base and its height what do we think
its area is going to be
so at first it might seem well you know
this isn't this isn't as obvious as if
we're dealing with a rectangle but we
can do a little visualization that i
think will help so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to take a chunk of area
from the left hand side actually this
triangle on the left hand side that
helps make up the parallelogram and then
move it to the right and then we will
see something somewhat amazing
so i'm going to take this
i'm going to take this little chunk
right there
actually i need to copy it let me do it
a little bit better so this
i'm going to take
that chunk right there and let me cut
and paste it so it's still the same
parallelogram but i'm just going to move
this section of area remember we're just
thinking about how much how much is
space is inside of the parallelogram and
i'm going to take this area right over
here and i'm going to move it to the
right hand side
and what just happened what just
happened let me see if i can move it a
little bit better what just happened
when i did that
well notice it now looks just like my
previous rectangle that just by taking
some of the area by taking some of the
area in the left and moving it to the
right i have reconstructed this
rectangle so they actually have the same
area the area of this parallelogram or
what used to be the parallelogram before
i move that triangle from the left to
the right is also going to be the base
times the height so the area here is
also
the area here is also base times height
because once again i just took this
chunk of area that was over there and i
moved it to the right so the area of a
parallelogram the area let me make this
looking more like a parallelogram again
the area of a parallelogram
is just going to be if you have the base
and the height it's just going to be the
base times the height so the area for
both of these the area for both of these
are just
base times height